I promise you I'm gonna take from him what he took from you
You aren't a listener
I want him to suffer.. for everything that he's done
A race, Barry!
Between you and me
To see who's the fastest man alive
You want revenge. If that's why you're doing this you will lose
Run, Barry! Run!
Hey YouTubers! This is Charlie.
This is gonna be my Flash finale trailer video.
Just Careful for spoilers for everything that's happened on the season so far
'cause we have to tralk about what happened in the last episode,
and there's some CRAZY wtf.
The timeline of the footage isn't super specific
There's a funeral.. the way they cut the trailer makes it seem like he has a small fight with Zoom
Then there's a time jump
The funeral happens,
then we see this final race, you know.. "Let's see who's the fastest once and for all"
in what looks like the TV show's version of the actual cosmic treadmill
The actual title of the episode is 'Race of His Life'
so that probably has something to do with what zoom is using this giant treadmill for.
Now I'm just calling it the cosmic treadmill. But who knows what the actual name for it will be?
But that might have something to do with Earth-2 being destroyed like Cisco sees in his visions
When I first heard cosmic treadmill, I really just thought of this, like in the original story
of Hunter Zolomon becoming Zoom,
he gets on the cosmic treadmill
to try and go back in time so that he can heal himself
because in the comics, he lost the use of his legs
Wally West, who was the Flash at that time and was his good friend
refused to change the timeline.
So Zolomon attempted to use the cosmic treadmill,
caused this HUGE accident that gave him speed force powers
That.. They work a little differently from previous Reverse Flashes
but this was all pre Flash Rebirth Wally West era Flash stuff
This was one of the last big Geoff Johns Flash runs before he did Flash Rebirth and Barry Allen and became the main Flash
Now there IS a Flash Rebirth happening next week
but it's like a big DC Universe rebirth..
It's completely unrelated to what's happening on the TV show.
When you're thinking about comic book stuff to Flash TV show stuff
especially with cosmic treadmill,
Zoom versus The Flash,
just think of imagery. The actual plot of a lot of those Wally West stories are gonna be much like what they're gonna do on the TV show.
The TV show has gone with different characters so it borrows things from the comics
but usually it's just ideas, or names, or characters
They mix n match things.
So what about Jay Garrick and the man in the iron mask?
We were promised a reveal, we're gonna find out who's underneath that mask
I think we're all hoping that it's the real Jay Garrick
and it's going to be played by John Wesley Ship
Remember? His mother's maiden name IS Garrick
So even if it's not john Wesley Ship, it's going to be someone from his family.
Barry will probably be related to Jay Garrick.
Now keep in mind it's till an Earth-2 person.. so there's all kinds of twists going into season 3
and it'll be really hard to guess the direction they'll take it in season 3 until we actually see what's going on
in the finale. So lemme know in the comments
Do you think because they killed off Henry Allen, they're just clearing the way for a John Wesley Ship Jay Garrick?
Well, you know, whatever the explanation is, whether it's Barry's dad from Earth-2
or it's his grandfather or some twist like that
Just keep in mind that the actor who plays Zoom said that he's basically going to be dealt with
in the finale but he's not going away completely
It's kind of like the Eobard Thawne Reverse Flash
Barry defeated him in the season 1 finale
but then we saw him come back during season 2
So Zoom can always come back in the future whatever the resolution is
but a bunch of different people from behind the scenes like producers, people associated with the TV show
have said the comic book fans will really like what ends up happening in the finale  the BIG Twist
So that makes me feel like we're gonna see the real Jay Garrick.
It'll be like Jay Garrick Rebirth.. like we saw Barry Allen in Flash Rebirth
AND this big cosmic treadmill is going to have universe altering consequences
Now I don't know how they're gonna integrate Supergirl season 2 with Earth-1 next year because
Cisco would still have to open a breach to get to Supergirl's Earth
So they might find some creative way around that
If there IS gonna be some universe altering consequence of this cosmic treadmill race here,
then I think it's mostly gonna be associated with Earth-1, Earth-2
but just think about how they keep broadening the mythology from season to season on The Flash and Arrow
They've already been teasing things on Legends of Tomorrow
Things are getting way more comic book-y, way bigger
So lemme know. What do you think the deal with the cosmic treadmill is?
We've already talked about Jay Garrick. But now, like, what is going to be the side effect
of them going CRAZY on this cosmic treadmill here?
There will probably be some extra giveaways next week because of all the finales.. because of all the rebirth stuff happening..
So I'll try to think of something cool
But I WILL go ahead and start a new round of the giveaway now.
So all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video
If there's any other bonus videos you guys want me to do next week, just let me know
A lot of it will depend on waht happens in the finale.
Like if we see Jay garrick, i'll totally do a Jay Garrick video
But just make sure that you don't wait to watch THe Flash and Arrow finales next week
Make sure to watch them the night that they air
While you guys wait for my next video to post,
you can click here for this week's episode of The Flash
and you can click here for my Star Trek Beyond and my Star Trek TV series trailer
There's a new Star Trek TV series that CBS is working on. So,
Thank you so much for watching, everybody!
Let's high five, I'll see you guys tonight!